[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Morning.
My name is Yufeng Guo, and I
host a video series on YouTube
called AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
I wanted to bring a little piece
of that, here today, in person.
So let's go on an AI
adventure together.
For the purposes
of this session,
let's start with just a short
definition of machine learning,
and use that to
build up a workflow
and get into the tools.
We'll then, use
that today to help
us see how we can solve
machine-learning problems,
and see how we can use that
to apply to your problems
outside of I/O.
And so, we'll say
that machine learning
is programming with data.
And we'll use that data to
create a system or model which
is trained to do some task.
And we train this model,
very importantly, using data.
And so, everything
comes back to the data.
So that's really the
first step of machine
learning-- gathering your data.
It all centers and
starts from there.
Next, there's typically
some kind of preparation
needed of that data.
The raw data is often
not so suitable for use.
And so, we need to
prepare it a little
before it's ready for
your machine learning.
Third, we'll need
to choose a model
we want to use, then,
train it up, and evaluate
its performance, do
some fine tuning,
and finally, make those
predictions-- do those tasks.
So we'll go through each
of these seven steps
in detail, over the
course of this session.
So first, let's
see what question
we are trying to use our model
to address in the first place.
We'll walk through a
simple example dataset,
and go through these seven steps
using the task to categorize
some data about animals.
We're going to say, what
kind of animal is this,
based on some input data.
Is it a bird?
Is it a mammal?
Is it a reptile fish,
or amphibian, a bug,
or invertebrate?
One of these seven types.
And it will be based on a
variety of different stats
about a given animal.
So our model will take in this
data, this structured data,
and use that to try to make a
prediction-- one of these seven
types of animals.
Now that we know what
kind of situation
we're modeling,
let's dive into each
of these steps in more detail.
First up, is gathering data.
Just because we
know what problem
we are trying to solve
for, it doesn't always
mean that we have the
data needed to solve it.
And without data, your
model is going nowhere.
So ask yourself this, where does
my data live, in what format,
and how can I get to it?
These are oftentimes the
early stumbling blocks
as we try to use data to solve
and address our problems.
And perhaps, you're
actually in a situation
where you don't have
all the data you need.
You need to collect
your own data.
This is also a common use case.
And you can get creative
in solving this problem
by building some systems
for data collection,
perhaps you make it a game.
One really interesting
example of this is Quickdraw.
Quickdraw is an
online game that lets
you draw a specific
picture and tries
to predict what you're drawing.
So it tells you draw a
basketball, or draw a boat.
And you know, it's kind of fun.
People like it.
And as a result, the
game has generated
over 1 billion doodles
of hand-drawn images
from around the world.
And this dataset is
open sourced on GitHub.
And there's actually an AI
Adventures episode that we just
put out if you want to learn
more about using this dataset
and playing with that.
But back to our steps.
We've gathered our data.
What's next?
Well, we've got to
prepare that data.
Data preparation could be its
own separate talk entirely.
So we'll just touch
on a few aspects here.
Explore your data before you do
any kind of machine learning.
It can really help you
understand your data better,
and this is fundamental
because it gives you
this intuition
about your data set,
and can save you a ton
of time and headache
later on in the process.
And so, I really encourage
folks to clean their data,
to look at the data, and kind
of get some intuition about it.
It helps you identify
gaps, and you'll
learn a lot about what you're
working with along the way.
And maybe you'll find that
you actually need more data
or that certain pieces
of data you collected
weren't actually so
useful after all.
One tool I like to play with
to do this is called Facets.
We'll take a little brief
detour and talk about that.
Facets is an open source
data-visualization
tool from Google
Research, and it
can help you get a better sense
of your data distribution.
And yes, there are lots
of tools that enable
you to do very similar things.
You can write out commands
and call functions,
but this one puts
it all in one place.
And because it's a
UI, you won't forget
to compute a
particular statistic
or look into some
corner of the data
because it's all
computed for you.
It just shows up.
And so, you can just
kind of browse it.
And so here, we can see
Facets applied to our data set
of these animals from
the zoo, and most of them
are kind of ones and zero
data sets of does it breathe?
Does it have a tail?
Does it have feathers?
Things like that.
And so that's why we see this
kind of funny distribution on 0
to 1.
But a lot of times, with
numerical distributions,
you'll see something
far more interesting.
Now, let's move on to
our third step of machine
learning-- choosing a model.
And we'll discuss a little
bit about model selection,
how we might go about
doing this using
the least effort possible.
And first, let's build
an intuition around
what is happening when a
machine-learning model is
working well.
So here, we see how
the model is trying
to divide up a region,
where we're trying to say,
which side is blue,
which side is orange,
to match the data,
which are the dots.
So it's not the hardest
example in the world.
Right?
Everything's already kind
of separated forever--
separated out.
But let's look at something
a little more interesting.
Here, we see the model
struggle for a little bit
as it tries to find a way to
draw that enclosing circle
around the blue dots.
And it's really neat to
see that these tools are
available to you today, which
are sophisticated enough
to handle all of
the minutia for you.
So you don't really need to
worry about the details of how
it's getting about it.
It's just a matter of is
it achieving the task.
But it is fun to see.
And different models can
model different kinds of data,
and different degrees
of complexity.
So that's what model
selection is really about.
It's about seeing what
model is the right fit
for your particular data set,
and the particular problem
you're trying to solve.
Now concretely, what
we are going to do
is use TensorFlow
to achieve this.
So there's lots of
talks about TensorFlow
here at I/O this year, so
I won't rehash those bits.
But we'll see an
example, perhaps,
of what it might look like
to use TensorFlow to do model
selection, to actually
write that code, especially
if you haven't had too
much hands on experience
with TensorFlow,
this may be kind
of a useful look at just
how accessible it can be.
So this is an example
of a linear classifier.
It's similar to the
first animation we saw.
It's good for a drawing a
linear line between two spaces.
And we can see that it's
pretty straightforward.
But what if we had
more complex data?
This one-line call, well, it
kind of stays a one-line call
when you try to try it
out on a different model.
So we're going to replace this
with a deep neural network,
and it only takes
a few small tweaks.
And in this case, we just have
to add one additional argument
called hidden units.
This defines the
structure of our network.
In this case, we have
three layers with 30, 20,
and 10 neurons in them.
And so, all we needed
to do is, literally,
just change the name--
just replace that text,
and add one argument.
You don't have to replumb
your entire system.
You don't have to delete
everything and start
from scratch.
So that's really neat.
And it's similar for
other models you can try.
A lot of them just involve
one flip of the model--
of the method call,
and you can basically
play around with these
different menu of choices.
And so, in that
paradigm it allows
you to not have to commit
to a model beforehand.
You can try one out, see how
it does, and then come back.
So these seven steps,
you work through,
and you can iterate back.
You can always go back
and cycle through.
And so, that brings
us to our next step.
We've gathered our data.
We've prepared it.
We've chosen a model,
for now at least.
And now, we can do the training.
Training gets a
lot of attention,
because in some ways, that's
where the magic happens.
But in practice, it's
often very straightforward.
You just let it
run, and you wait.
So let's take a look at what
happens during the training,
and then we can see it in code.
Conceptually, when training
a model, we pass in our data,
and we ask the model right away
to try to make a prediction.
But the prediction
will be pretty bad
because our model is
initialized randomly.
But we make this prediction,
and we take it and compare it
to the true answer, the
correct answer that we know.
And we use that information
to update the model.
And so, each time we go
through and update the model
with a new piece
of data as it works
its way through
the training set,
it allows the model to get
better and better over time
with each training loop.
And so, that's what the
training process looks like.
But in practice, when you
actually need to code it up,
we take our function
we created the model,
and we just called
dot train on it.
It's, literally, one line.
You just need to
provide a function that
gives it the training data
inputs, and that's it.
It's one line.
And so, once the
training completes--
if you run this function, you
go off and you grab a sandwich,
and you come back, and
it's time to do evaluation.
We got to evaluate our model.
It's to see how accurate it is--
see if it's doing a good job
of performing its primary task.
So we can show it some
examples of things
that we know the
correct answers to,
and the model did not see
those questions in training.
It didn't see that
data in training.
So we use this evaluation
data that we set aside
to measure the
performance of our model.
And conceptually, it looks
very similar to training.
It's still this same shape.
But the important
difference is that there's
no arrow at the top.
It's not a closed loop.
The model does not get updated
once we check its prediction
results.
And so, if we did
update the model,
then it would be no
different than training,
and we'd be
essentially cheating.
So the evaluation data is
kind of precious in that way.
We don't use it to
update the model.
We hold it aside,
and we reserve it
for evaluating the
performance of our model.
In code, it's just as simple
as everything else we've seen.
We just call dot evaluate.
You want to evaluate,
you call dot evaluate.
And notice, that we are
passing in evaluation data.
It's an eval input function.
So it's not the training data.
And if we were using
the training data--
let's say, we copied
that line down.
We just swapped out,
trained for evaluate,
and we forgot to
change the data source.
Now we're evaluating the
performance of our model using
the training data, and that
would be a big mistake,
because the model has optimized
itself for the training data.
And so, if you evaluate using
that same data, what happens
is you misrepresent the true
performance of your model,
and it will likely perform
poorly on real-world data
once you deploy it,
since it's never seen
and you've never
measured how it does
with previously unseen data.
So this brings us
to our next point.
How can we actually
improve our model then?
We ran the training.
We did this thing.
We ran the evaluation.
Now what?
Do we run training some more?
How can we tweak it further?
We could always swap
out for a new model.
But what if we've
decided on this model,
but we want to improve it as is?
This is where hyper-parameter
tuning comes in.
These models have
parameters of their own,
but what values should we use?
And how do we pick them?
Much like how you can
try out different models,
you can also try out lots of
different model parameters.
This process called
hyper-parameter tuning,
in some ways, still remains
an active area of research.
But that doesn't mean that you
can't take advantage of it.
Conceptually, we
take our training,
and instead of just training one
model, we'll tweak that model,
and create a couple
of different variants.
And so we'll run training
on different variants
of the same underlying model,
but with different model
parameters, and see how
that affects our accuracy.
So we'll train and evaluate
all of these different variants
of the same, or similar,
models, and then
see which one performs best.
That's how it informs
our parameter choice.
But you see, a lot of
that is experimental.
You've got to try them
to see what works.
So you might have to
break out your four loop.
And so, Yeah, the task of
choosing good hyper-parameters
is something, perhaps
you've intuited this,
you could probably turn into
a machine-learning problem
itself--
optimizing the
parameters for the model
that you're using
for machine learning.
But we'll have to save
that for another talk.
So we've gathered data.
We've prepared it, chosen
a model and trained it,
evaluated the data, and we
tuned the hyper-parameters.
At long last, we have
reached our last step,
making those predictions.
This is the whole
point of training up
the model in the first place.
It wasn't just to get
a really good accuracy,
or to create heat on our server.
It was to actually do
something useful with it.
And so, making predictions,
we take the model
and we deploy it somewhere,
or we isolate it out,
and we can show the model
some data that it hasn't
been trained on, and then
see what kind of outputs
it predicts.
And so, that's our seven steps--
conceptual seven steps
of machine learning.
But let's see what it actually
looks like in practice.
We'll turn to the
tooling side of things
and look at what you use,
beyond just TensorFlow,
and how you might actually
achieve these seven steps.
So we're going to go
and look at some code,
and in particular, I'll
feature a couple of tools
we'll get hands
on with, and I'll
point you to some additional
resources as well.
First up, is a
tool called Co Lab.
If you've ever worked with any
sort of notebook environment
or a REPL on the
web before, this
is basically a way to run
Python in the browser.
But not just run Python, it's
a whole notebook environment.
You can put mark down, the
code actually executes,
and because it's hosted,
essentially on Google Drive,
you can share it
with other people.
So let's switch
over to the demo,
and I can show you what it
looks like to use CO Lab.
So here we see--
and I've loaded
up Co Lab, and we
can run various
commands-- all the things
that we would expect.
So let's see, we're still
connected, and in Co Lab,
because it's a
notebook environment,
you have to upload
your own files.
And it connects to the internet,
so you can also authenticate
and pull things down.
In my case, I have our
dataset loaded on the machine.
And so, we can download that.
And I've got pandas loaded here.
So we can take a
look at our data set.
As promised, it's
a bunch of animals
and a bunch of statistics,
and at the very end,
there is a class type.
And so Co Lab, it really lets
you just execute the code
on the screen in a--
well, in real time.
And Moreover, because it's
all hosted on Google Drive,
I don't have to spin up any
machines in the background.
It just works seamlessly.
And you can put comments in
and share your work with others
and--
[INAUDIBLE] there we go--
and do collaborative research,
or just work, in general.
So that's really neat.
And so-- let's see--
I think we have some
time, so let's actually
walk through a little bit of
what I've ended up doing here.
We took our data,
and what I'm doing
is shuffling it, and
then splitting the data.
So we had a whole data set.
This whole dataset happens to
just be 101 different animals.
So it's probably
the smallest dataset
that I've probably come across.
But you still need to do the
same types of best practices.
In this case, I've
taken it and split it
into training and
evaluation data.
Because if I use all
101 to do training,
what am I going to do
to evaluate my model?
So we'll split it.
In this case, I chose a
fraction of 60% and 40%,
but that ratio can be adjusted.
And so, we can see, we have our
training data-- all 60 values.
And then, we have our
evaluation data below.
And I do a little
bit of preprocessing.
So this is the
processing your data bit.
Notably, the last column of
the data set is the label.
It is the answer--
one through seven of what
the correct type of animal
it is-- reptile, amphibian,
mammal, et cetera.
The problem is the labels
go from one to seven,
and I need them to
be zero through six,
in this particular case.
So I just shift it by
one, by subtracting one,
and then that's it.
So pretty simple preprocessing.
I would expect that a
bigger data, perhaps,
would do more things.
And so, we can see
that our data--
apparently, I didn't
make this run--
run-- always run your code.
And our input function here
is pretty straightforward.
It takes our raw data, and
if we want it to be shuffled,
we can call a shuffle
on our data set.
And I just let it repeat and
batch into chunks as needed.
And so, this will just feed
right into the training.
I believe there was a
talk about data sets
specifically, earlier
at I/O. So if you missed
that, you can
catch the recording
or roll back the live stream.
So we have our dataset--
or our input function.
And I think I forgot
to run the cell again.
And this is a little
cell I have here
to just try out
my input function,
to make sure it's working--
always good to test things.
And so, we can see that my
input function is indeed
returning all the data of each
types of the feathers, what
has eggs, what is airborne,
does it have a backbone--
things like that.
And so, each of these arrays
represent a batch of data.
And I was also playing
around with this
to check out the unique
values for each column just
to make sure that most of
them are ones and zeros,
but there's a couple of here
that are a little bit strange.
For example, there are animals
with five legs, apparently.
So not all data
sets are perfect.
And TensorFlow uses this
notion of feature columns
to represent the incoming data.
Models are pretty generic, and
so, by using feature columns,
it allows you to customize it
for your particular dataset.
In our case, I just loop over
all the data-- all the columns,
all 17 of them, which
happen to be numeric,
and set that as numeric.
So it's really just
a configuration
to let TensorFlow know how
many columns and of what type
are coming in.
So we'll run that.
And if things break,
it's because I
forgot to run the cell, so
yell at me if that happens.
And so, here is that
line that we saw before
with the creating a model.
So here, we'll create
a linear classifier,
and pull in those
feature columns,
and say that there are seven
different classes-- seven
different possible
values for the animals.
And I've combined
the train and eval--
the train and evaluate
calls into a function
just for convenience, so
that they both run together.
I want it to run the training
on the training data,
and I want to run the evaluation
on the evaluation data.
So wrapping this
together helps make
sure you don't introduce
bugs as you rerun cells
as you go along.
So let's say we run
the linear model,
and we just let that turn.
And so this is all backed
by Google's servers,
and apparently, it is
taking its sweet time.
While it's doing that--
well, this one's done.
So we got 90%, which
is like OK, right?
There was only 100 rows.
We took 60 of them for training,
and used 40 for evaluation,
so it's not the most
reliable metric.
The idea here is that
the tooling is there.
The code is there.
You should replace this
with your own data, which
will be much better
than this data set,
and get awesome results.
So as promised, the deep
neural network is very similar.
It's, literally,
the same as before,
but I replaced it
with hidden units.
I guess, there's one
notable difference,
is that I do take
the old feature
columns that we had from
before, and we wrap it
in an indicator column.
So that's just a space to
put the linear networks
data into a way that the deep
neural network can represent.
So it's a little bit out
of scope for this talk,
but it's an adjustment just
for deep neural networks
and linear networks
don't have to deal with.
So we'll let that get created.
Oops-- just created a new cell.
So, I guess, that's also a
good thing to show off here.
So we can very easily create
code blocks and cell blocks
in between, and you can have
all sorts of great editing
abilities here.
And you can turn
it into markdown.
You execute the cell.
And it'll be there.
So with the deep network--
I forget if I ran this.
Maybe we'll run it again.
We can also push
the model further.
The percentages here
are sometimes wonky,
because they are--
because there's only 40
values in the evaluation data,
this is effectively-- something
over 40 is getting it right,
and then the other
ones are wrong.
So in this case, it looks like
that 10%, probably about four
are wrong-- or three
or four are incorrect.
So let's make some predictions,
and see what got missed.
TensorFlow also has a
dot predict function,
just like it dot train
and dot evaluate.
And so, you can pass in--
I just took the evaluation
data and sliced out a couple
of examples to take a look at.
So we can see here
that when we do that,
you get the prediction
and the correct answer.
So in this case, those five
that I arbitrarily chose,
happened to work out.
But what if we wanted to see the
exact ones that we got wrong?
So this was a little
experiment I ran
just because I was curious--
which ones were the linear
network getting wrong
and which ones were the
deep network getting wrong?
In this case, they're different.
They got the same number
of incorrect predictions.
They all have four wrong,
but they're actually
different examples.
And so, this would be an
opportunity to dig in further,
and play around with that.
One final thing I'll add here is
that Co Lab, or Co Laboratory,
has GPU support.
And so, you can
toggle on GPU, so
if you have big data sets
and big fancy models,
and you want to access that sort
of stuff, go and get that GPU.
And so, let's switch
back to the slides
briefly, and take a
look at another tool.
Aside from CO Lab,
there is another tool
that we have that's
very similar.
It's also notebook based, and
you might have heard of it.
It's called Kaggle.
And while Kaggle is most
known for its competitions
or discussion forums
and data sets,
it also has a feature
called Kernels.
And Kernels is really just
a fancy name for notebook.
And the Kernels look
something like this.
This might start to look
familiar from Co Lab,
except it's blue.
And Kernels is different
in a couple of subtle ways.
Firstly, I want to--
let's switch over to the
demo for Kaggle Kernels
and we'll see what
that looks like.
How's that?
So I took the notebook that
we had earlier in Co Lab,
and I downloaded
the notebook itself
as an IPython notebook file.
And since Kaggle has
data sets, we actually
have a zoo animal
classification dataset.
How convenient that I
chose the exact dataset
that already exists on Kaggle.
And so, we can click
New Kernel, and I'm
going to choose notebook.
And Kaggle Kernels not
only run in Python,
but you can also choose to run
them in R, for those of you who
prefer R. And what I
can do is I can actually
upload a notebook--
well, first I need to
download that notebook.
So let's do that.
So from Co Lab,
we will download--
this is what I get
for zooming in a lot--
download the book.
And then, once
it's downloaded, we
can upload that notebook
back into Kaggle Kernels.
And so-- boom.
We have that same
notebook now in Kernels.
There is one small tweak.
Because we had to upload a
file from the local drive,
for Co Lab, we're going
to get rid of that.
And the only other tweak is that
it in Kaggle Kernels, the data
lives in one directory
up called input.
So if I run the first cell, and
then we'll work our way down,
we'll see that the
data lives in input,
and it's the same kind of thing.
And since we already saw
the rest of the notebook,
it's, literally, the same thing.
What is interesting, though,
is that in kernels, we can--
let's see-- let's
give it a name.
And we can commit that notebook.
And what Kaggle
Kernels does is it
will run your notebook in
a new fresh environment,
separate from the
session that you're in.
This will generate a notebook
with all of the outputs
that we've been seeing in a kind
of nice view-only format, which
is really useful for sharing.
Because what if you want
to share your notebook,
as well as how it was
executed, to others.
You want reproducible
notebooks, and so that's
kind of what we see here.
So we ran our notebook.
It's done.
And we can view that snapshot.
So it's kind of
like a GitHub model
of like you can commit
versions of your notebook.
And so, by default, your
notebooks are private.
And we can see here that things
ran, the outputs are shown,
and I didn't have to go through
and run these one by one.
And if I ran these cells
out of order, manually,
earlier, to yield
my results, running
them top to bottom
like this will
help catch those
kinds of bugs that
would help with the--
make it hard to reproduce
my performance down the
road, when I come back
to this next week,
or next month.
And if you share your notebooks,
you can then fork them.
You can fork them.
You can also get others
to fork your notebooks,
as well as add collaborators
to your notebooks.
You can add users to join
you on the same notebook,
rather than just forking them.
So there's a lot of great
collaboration models
across Co Lab and
Kaggle, depending
on your particular use case.
And, I guess, it would be good
to also just briefly mention
that like Co Lab, we can also
enable GPUs in Kaggle Kernels
as well.
So don't let that be a
deciding factor for you.
So that's Kaggle Kernels.
Let's switch back
over to the slides
and talk about just a few
other little tools and tips
and tricks, before
we wrap things up.
And if we could switch
back to the slides--
awesome.
So let's say, you
don't want notebooks.
Let's say, you try notebooks
and they just weren't for you,
or you have a bigger workload.
You need to run a
long running job.
It's got to run for hours.
Or you have a
really big data set,
and it doesn't fit
in Kaggle Kernels,
or it doesn't fit on
your local directory,
so you're not going to
upload it to drive manually.
Then, you can use something like
Cloud Machine Learning Engine
where you can kick off a job
to run-- a long running job--
that maybe runs across a
set of distributed machines,
all of them potentially
with GPUs attached.
And once you're done, you
might want to serve your model.
You want to make
those predictions.
But perhaps, you want
to do it at scale.
You're building an app.
You train a model,
and you want to create
a rest endpoint that can serve
predictions to the world.
And so, machine-learning
engine also
includes an auto-scaling
prediction service.
You can, literally, just
take your TensorFlow model,
give it a name, and be done--
literally point to the
file and give it a name.
There aren't any other
steps, because you
can't do anything else, in terms
of creating a model to serve,
which is really neat.
And if you are working with
things like scikit-learn
or [INAUDIBLE] boost, and you
want to serve those as well,
we'll take those too.
And so, then you don't
have to deal with the ops
aspect of machine learning, you
can just play with your data,
tweak your model, train it,
and deploy it with ease.
And I think most--
not most, but many of you--
are also perhaps aware of
the machine-learning APIs
that are also available.
These are pretrained APIs
for doing various tasks.
They're a little more canned.
You don't provide
your own data, but it
does mean that everything
just works out of the box.
You need something-- you
need a picture to be turned
into a description, you need
audio to be turned into text,
it just works.
And so, that's kind of nice.
But the limitations, of course,
are that you can't customize it
for your specific use case.
That is still something
you'll have to just wait
a little bit longer for.
With the one notable
exception of Vision.
So the auto ML, Vision is
available right now in alpha,
and so you can apply for
that, and supply your own data
sets to train and customize
your own Vision API.
So that's kind of like
a neat side tangent.
The animations that
we saw earlier,
that I showed, with the
orange and blue dots
came from the
TensorFlow Playground.
So if you want to play
around with a neural network
in your browser and just
like toggle things on and off
and just mess around, head over
to Playground.TensorFlow.org
and you can do that right there.
And don't worry,
you can't break it.
It's just through browser.
You can only break
your own machine.
And so what's next?
The code that we just saw is--
I made it public.
It's on Kaggle.
So it's at
Kaggle.com/yufeng/zoo-demo.
If you want to learn
more about TensorFlow,
head on over to TensorFlow.org.
And thirdly, there is a
machine-learning crash course
that Google released recently.
And so, if you want
to learn-- really dive
into the concepts
of machine learning,
go further than what we've
talked about here today,
head over there.
There's basically
a whole curriculum
of videos and assignments
that you can do, and really
build up your
machine-learning knowledge.
And finally, if you're
interested in doing machine
learning in the cloud,
you can head over
to the Cloud dome,
the white tent
next to the Google
Assistant dome.
Or head on over to
cloud.Google.com/machinelearning
or /ml.
As I mentioned at the
beginning, I host a video series
by the same name as the
session, AI Adventures.
We explore some
interesting nugget
in each episode about
machine learning,
and try to do some hands-on
demos once in a while,
and do some interviews
with interesting folks.
So hopefully you'll check
it out and subscribe.
So I want to thank you for
joining me in this session,
and we really--
you know, I'd really appreciate
feedback on the session,
information, so please head
on over to the schedule,
and you can log in and
give some feedback.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]